doña ángela cree por momentos que lo que
está sucediendo es ficción pero cuando
siente el peso de la realidad se
derrumba
en este mundo
es la mamá de kevin anthony agudelo el
joven murió con 22 años en la noche del
3 de mayo de 2021 en el barrio de siloé
de cali por un disparo que le atravesó
el cuerpo presuntamente disparado por la
policía porque fue vilmente asesinado
eso no le puede llamar otra obra que
asesinato
kevin era su único hijo no pudo entrar a
la universidad por falta de recursos
tras realizar estudios técnicos
intentaba mantenerles económicamente con
sus primeras experiencias laborales era
las botas de trabajo
madre e hijo dormían juntos en una
habitación en casa de la abuela la
presencia de kevin se siente en todos
los rincones para colgar entre
fotografías de kevin angela se aferra al
recuerdo de su hijo amante del fútbol
familias y niños estaban el 3 de mayo en
la glorieta de entrada al barrio popular
de siloé homenajeaban a los muertos en
las protestas del paro nacional en
colombia pero un operativo policial
irrumpió en la comuna
jonathan de 16 años lo vivió en primera
persona es aquí fue el peatón en esa
parte se lo devuelve latón donde
seguimos la gente procesando muy cerca
murió que vince allí antes jonathan
había atendido a un herido aquí pues
antes yo trabaja el muchacho el que le
pegaron la bala en el pie el pues que yo
lo traje aquí aquí están los paramédicos
y yo y en el siguiente escondite se topó
con el horror y ahí fue que está la
sangre el el disparo y la cara él todos
han hecho reo en la cara
frente a las pesadillas los sueños
jonathan quiere encontrar una esperanza
en el fútbol mi sueño es el fútbol
porque yo veo grandes famosos dando lo
mejor cada día vienen de barrios también
así como el mío pero ellos nunca se
detuvieron con ello sin embargo no es
fácil crecer en siloé uno de cada cinco
niños vive en pobreza extrema la
situación económica de jonathan en
pandemia ha sido crítica hay veces que
nos acostamos sin comer pero mi mamá ha
hecho lo posible y me ha mirado así sea
un pan con café
para poder conseguir sus sueños jonathan
entrena todos los días en este campo de
fútbol perjudicado por las lluvias los
chicos son los encargados de rehabilitar
la cancha cuando se inunda
de un compromiso social inculcado por
este no ver valència a su entrenador
quien se vuelve un padre para ellos ante
la falta de referentes paternos datos
oficiales de 2017 indican que el 56% de
mujeres colombianas son cabeza de
familia en este entrenamiento conversan
sobre lo ocurrido en la noche del 3 de
mayo en siloé cuando murió el compañero
kevin antonio agudelo
[Música]
por el hecho de que
por un instante y luego un barrio muy
peligroso y hunosa que en cualquier
momento uno es al que llegamos a la
tienda o entrenar y salga lo malo
el compromiso es tal que este nobel vive
frente al campo de fútbol por su casa
siempre pasa alguno de sus jugadores
jonathan james fue su primer jugador y
ahora es su ayudante considera que el
deporte es una de las únicas salidas
para los jóvenes y es como también una
forma donde los muchachos hoy en día
solucionan un poquito sus problemas de
oportunidad
miguelangel álzate es uno de los
jugadores que ha conseguido salir de la
delincuencia las drogas y de la muerte
con fútbol pero también con la religión
muy presente en el barrio
y la clave es buscar de esa disciplina
este no haber espera conseguir que algún
empresario financia su carrera para que
no corra la misma suerte que los 15
jugadores que han muerto de forma
violenta desde 2009 cuando se fundó el
fc del valle
el abandono del estado deja pocas
oportunidades a los jóvenes de siloé y
en pandemia se ha agravado en 2020 el
desempleo en el barrio creció por encima
del 20%
david gómez líder social de la comuna
nos muestra el barrio desde el cable
considera que el paro nacional ha
despertado a una nueva generación porque
es una lucha del joven y lo entendemos y
lo respetamos nosotros para ello no
hicimos nada por este país en la comuna
viven unas 100.000 personas
las casas suben por la loma son
viviendas que se fueron construyendo
ante la llegada de mineros campesinos
desplazados de la guerra y minorías
indígenas y afrodescendientes silo en
hebreo significa enviado
la palabra envía o no acción ahora el
barrio realmente digamos de que el
gobierno envíe tropas de gente que venga
a ayudar socialmente que nos podamos
tener universidades que podamos tener
una calidad de vida mejor que la que
tenemos en este momento
david trata de dar otra imagen de la
comuna en la que nació humanizando la y
librando la del estigma este es su museo
de la memoria y de la esperanza queremos
que a futuro siloé sea reconocido como
un territorio donde la gente no le dé
miedo entonces casa de tornillos memoria
esperanza y también presente en el museo
ya están los recuerdos del paro nacional
de 2021 destaca el homenaje a kevin que
murió en las protestas junto a decenas
de jóvenes colombianos soñando con un
país en el que nacer en barrios como
siloé no sea una condena